>> Okay Michael, so let's see if we can actually use this as a way
of deriving something maybe that we already
knew. So I'm going to go through a couple
of these because I I actually think,
well, frankly I just think it's kind of cool.
But, I I'm hoping I can convince you it's sort of cool too and that
we get something out of it. Okay, so let me set up the word, I'm
going to set up a a problem, and it's going to be a kind of generic problem,
and I'm going to see what we can get out of it, okay? So this is
machine learning, so we're going to be given a
bunch of data, so there are three assumptions
that I'm going to make here. The first is
that we're going to be given a bunch of labeled
training data, which I'm writing here as x sub i and d sub i, so x sub i
is whatever the input space is, and d sub i are these labels. And let's say, it
doesn't actually even matter what the labels are, but
let's say that the labels are classification labels. Okay?
>> Hm.
>> All right. And furthermore, not only we're given
this data as examples drawn from some underlying concept c,
but they're, in fact, noise-free. Okay? So they're
true examples that tell you what c is. Okay?
>> Mm-hm.
>> So I'm going to say, in fact, let me write
that down because I think it's important. They're noise-free examples. Okay.
>> Like di equals c of xi.
>> That's right, for all xi. So, the second assumption, is that the true
concept c, is actually in our hypothesis
space, whatever that hypothesis space is. And finally,
we have no reason to believe that
any particular hypothesis in our hypothesis space is
more likely than any other. And so, we have a uniform prior over our hypotheses.
>> So it's like the one thing we know is that we don't know anything.
>> That's right. So, sometimes people called this an uninformative prior
because you don't know anything. Except of course I've always thought that's
a terrible name because its a completely informative prior. In fact
its equally as informative as every other prior in that it tells
you something that all hypothesis are equally likely. But that's
>> I thought it was called an uninformed prior.
>> Is it? So its just an ignorant prior is what you're telling me. Yeah.
>> Okay. Well, then maybe that's the problem.
I just always had a problem with it
because people keep calling it uninformative and the
really mean uninformed. Okay. In any case, so these
are our, these are our assumptions. We've got
a bunch of data, it's noise free, the concept
is actually in the hypothesis base we care
about and we have a uniform prior. So we
need to compute the best hypothesis. So given
that we want to somehow compute the probability of
some hypothesis given the data, right? That's just
Bay's Rule. So, Michael, you've got the problem right?
>> Yes.
>> [LAUGH]
okay. So in order to compute the probability of a hypothesis
given the data, we just need to figure out all of these
other terms. So let me just write down some of the terms
and you can tell me what a you think the answer. Okay.
>> Well, what was the question?
>> The question is, while we want to compute some
kind of expression for the probability of a hypothesis given
the data. So given some particular hypothesis, I want to know
what's the probability of that hypothesis given the data, okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, you got the setup. So, we're
going to compute that by figuring out these three
terms over here. So, let's just pick, one
of them to do. Let's try the prior probability.
So Michael, what's the prior probability on H?
>> Did we say that it was a finite hypothesis class?
>> It is a finite hypothesis class.
>> Then it's like, one over the
size of that hypothesis class because it's uniform.
>> Exactly right, uniform means Exactly that. Okay so we've got one of our
terms, good job. let's pick another term. How about the probability of
data given the hypothesis. What's that?
>> The probability, so I guess noise free, and we know that it's
noise free so it's always, so they're always going to be zeros and ones.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, and it's going to be a question of whether or not
the data is consistent with that hypothesis. Right, if the labels all match.
>> Right.
>> What we expect them to be if that really were the hypothesis, then
we get a one, otherwise we get a zero. That's exactly right. So let me
see if I can write down what I think you just said. The probability of the data,
given the hypothesis, is, therefore one if it's the case, that the labels
And the hypothesis agree for every single one of the training exercises. Right?
>> Yep
>> Is that what you said? Good. And if any of
them disagree, then the probability is zero. So that's actually very important.
It's important to, to understand exactly what it means for,
to have the probability to get a hypothesis, as we
mentioned before. That the English version of this is, what's
the probability that I would see data with these labels in
a universe where H is actually true. Which is different
from saying that H is trure or H is false. It's
really a common about the labels that you see on
a data. In a universe, where H happens to be true.
>> Okay, but you know, it's occurring to me now
that you wrote that down, that we've talked about this idea before.
>> When?
>> Well, so, like there's a shorter way of writing that. Which is
D of H equals one if H is in the version space of D.
>> Huh, that's exactly right, that's exactly right. So, in
fact, that will help us to compute the final term
that we need, which is the probability of seeing the
data labels. So, how do we go about computing that? Well,
it's exactly going to boil down to the version space
as you say, let me just write out a couple
of steps so that it's pretty Kind of easy to
see. It's sometimes easier in these situations to kind of break
things up. So, the probability of the data sort of
formally, is equal to just this. So we can write the
probability of the data as being, basically, a marginalized version
of the probability of the data given each of the hypotheses
times the probability of the hypotheses. Now, this is only
true in a world where our hypotheses are mutually exclusive.
Okay so let's assume we are in that world because
frankly that's what we always assume and this little trick
is going to workout for us because we are going to
get to take advantage of two terms that we already
computed naming the probability that the data given the hypothesis
and the prior probability of a particular hypothesis so we know that
prior probability of a hypothesis is right, its
just one over the size of the hypothesis space
and how am I going to substitute in this equation
for the probability of the data given the hypothesis?
>> So, I don't know. I would
write that differently. I mean, it's basically it's
like the indicator function on whether or hot HI is in the version space of D.
>> Right, that's exactly right. So in fact this is not a good
way to have written it. Let's see if I can come up with a,
a good notational way of doing it. Let's
say, for every hypothesis that is in the
version space of the hypothesis space given the
labels that we've got. Okay? How's that count?
>> Okay.
>> So rather than having to come
up with an indicator function, I'm just going to
define vs as the subset of all
those hypotheses that are consistent with the data.
>> Yeah exactly
>> Okay, and so whats the probability of those?
>> One It's one and it's zero otherwise, so then,
we can simplify the sum and it's simply what? ?
>> The sum of the one, ooh! The
one of each doesn't even depend on the hypothesis.
>> mm-mh!
>> I see wait I don't see oh yes I do, I do it's one over the size
of version space. No its the size of the
version space over the size of the hypothesis space.
>> That's exactly right.
Basically for every single hypothesis in the version space we're
going to add one and how many of those are?
Well the size of the version space number of those.
And multiply all that by one over the size hypothesis space,
and so the probability of the data is that term. So
now we can just substitute all of that, into our
handy dandy equation up there, and let's just do that.
So the probability of the hypothesis given the data, is the
probability of the data given the hypothesis Which we know is one for all those
that are consistent, zero otherwise. The probability
of the prior probability over the hypothesis is
just one over the size of the hypothesis space, and the probability of the data
is the size of the version space Over the size of the hypothesis base which,
when we divide everything out, is simply this. Got it?
>> Got it.
>> So, what does that all say? It says that, given a bunch of data, your
probability of a particular hypothesis being correct, or being the best one
or the right one, is simply uniform over all of the hypotheses that are
in the version space. That is, are consistent with the data that we see.
>> Nice.
>> It
is kind of nice. And by the way, if it's
not consistent with it, then it's zero. So, this is
only true for hypotheses that are still in
version space and zero otherwise. Now notice that all of
this sort of works out only in a world
where you really do have noise free examples, and you
know that the concept is actually in your hypothesis space
and, just as crucially that you have a uniform prior
for all the hypotheses. Now this is exactly the algorithm that
we talked about before right. We talked about before what would
we do. To kind of decide whether a hypothesis was good
enough in this sort of noise-free world. And the answer we came
up with is you should just pick one of them that's
in the version space. And what this says is there's no reason
to pick one over the other from the version space. They're
all equally as good or rather equally as likely to be correct.
>> Yeah,
that follows.
>> Yeah. So there you go. So it turns out you
can actually do something with this. Notice by the way that we
did not pick a particular hypothesis space, we did not pick
a particular form of our instance space, we did not actually say
anything at all about exactly what the labels were other than
that they were labels of some sort. The strongest assumption that we
made was a uniform prior, so this is always the right thing
to do. At least in a Bayesen sense in a world where
you've got noise free data, you have to find that hypothesis space, and
you have uniform priors. Just pick
something from the consistent set of hypotheses.